[Musique]
la crevette et le crustacé le plus
consommé au monde
cette demande fait en sorte qu'on en
fait l'élevage à grande échelle
or nos analyses révèlent que certaines
crevettes contiennent des bactéries
pathogènes comme le colis ou salmonelles
et qui en plus résistants aux
antibiotiques ce qui est arrivé en
utilisant les antibiotiques depuis près
70 ans on exposait un grand nombre de
bactéries
un grand nombre de molécules et les
bactéries ont tout simplement sortis de
leur génome les manières de se défendre
80% des antibiotiques vendus dans le
monde sont destinés aux animaux
d'élevage
une pratique répandue consiste à leur en
donner à titre préventif dans leur
nourriture
c'est ce qu'on a fait un usage trop
intensif des antibiotiques dans le passé
on se ramasse avec avec une résistance
aux antibiotiques qui présente parmi ces
métaux nobles qui présente en médecine
humaine puis là on est à un moment où on
doit agir parce que des antibiotiques
sont efficaces donc sa menace nos
capacités à traiter les infections les
bactéries résistantes aux antibiotiques
sont une réelle menace pour nous ça si
on avale un produit que ce soit une
crevette morceaux de poulet ou un boeuf
qui est contaminée avec une bactérie
pathogène et qui résiste aux
antibiotiques
on risque de ne pas être capable d'être
traités certains humains mange une
bactérie qui viendront d'une crevette
piqué pathogènes ça veut dire qu'elle
est elle est capable de causer une
infection souvent une infection gastro
intestinal ceci une seule bactérie le
streaming terre et peut-être capable
d'éclairer mais si c'est une quantité
grande ses plus grandes si la personne
est obligée de se présenter à l'hôpital
et là si on doit utiliser un
antibiotique la bactérie résistante qui
est à la fois sacré vert alors là on a
droit non un problème
d'où viennent dans les crevettes
contaminé l'épicerie a fait analyser en
collaboration avec nos collègues de
marketplace de cbe 6,51 sac de crevettes
crues et cuites acheter congelé dans des
supermarchés de toronto calgary montréal
et saskatoon
les analyses ont été effectuées par
l'équipe du docteur josef kluson de
l'université de la saskatchewan qui se
spécialise en surveillance de la
résistance aux antimicrobiens
le constat est inquiétant 14
échantillons sur 51 contenait des
bactéries potentiellement dangereuses et
neuf de ses échantillons étaient
porteurs de bactéries résistantes à au
moins un antibiotique la présence de
résistance aux antibiotiques dans ces
crevettes la confirme que ces animaux
l'on est exposé aux antibiotiques dans
plusieurs pays surtout des pays chauds
pour lequel il n'y a pas de contrôle
serré de l'usaj on va utiliser des
antibiotiques en grande quantité parce
que la nappe phréatique l'eau qu'on
utilise est contaminée
sur les neuf échantillons porteurs de
bactéries antibiorésistantes 5 venait de
l'inde 2 de chine et les deux autres de
thaïlande et du vietnam
c'est un enjeu mondial mais j'ai lorsque
ces composés utilisés au canada mais il
est utilisé en asie avec depuis le ca se
retrouve dans mon assiette
dans certaines crevettes la résistance
vient directement de l'utilisation
d'antibiotiques dans les bassins
d'élevage
pour d'autres ce sont les bassins
eux-mêmes qui pose problème
ceux ci sont parfois contaminés par des
eaux qui proviennent d' affluent dans
lesquels on déverse directement les
égouts
donc le accueilli le piège si elle est
lente et rob acteur c d origine ce soit
de matières fécales jeunes et matières
fécales mais c'est autant de l'humain
que des animaux sains alors à ce moment
là ça peut contaminer puis si c'est sûr
que c'est des bactéries qui peuvent
porter des résistances aux antibiotiques
parce que peut-être les humains où les
animaux ont été traités avec ces
antibiotiques l'oea ne sont pas de pays
comme l'asie où on parle de pays plus
amérique du sud ce moment là la
réglementation usage des antibiotiques
et plus tôt jeudi une existante donc ils
peuvent un peu parce qu'ils veulent
comme ils veulent
au canada l'usagé des antibiotiques est
très réglementée par exemple certaines
classes d'antibiotiques sont réservés
aux humains est interdite en préventif
chez des animaux interdit également
d'utiliser des antibiotiques pour
stimuler la croissance des animaux et au
canada on doit avoir une ordonnance d'un
vétérinaire pour y avoir accès le pays
encore bien usage des antibiotiques à ce
moment alors les antibiotiques sont
utilisés de façon judicieuse et adéquat
alors que dans d'autres pays
c'est moins réglementée donc ça peut
faire mettre de la résistance aux
antibiotiques avisés de nos résultats
santé canada nous indique que la lutte à
l'antibiorésistance est une priorité et
que le gouvernement songeait à inclure
les fruits de mer dans le programme de
surveillance ce qu'il ne fait pas
actuellement
quant aux compagnies qui vendent les
crevettes incriminés elles disent être
conformes aux normes d'importation des
fruits de mer au canada que la présence
de bactéries résistantes aux
antibiotiques dont les crevettes n'est
pas inhabituel et que le risque pour la
santé est éliminé par la cuisson à nous
donc de redoubler prudence dans le coeur
de tous ces bactéries losc sait où est
ce qu'elle se situe à ce que je
regardais bactérie e.coli captieux le
snapo réussi la salmonelle à la surface
de crever elles sont surtout à
l'extérieur de la crevette parce
qu'elles ont été en contamine à sion
avec l'environnement compte dont on
parlait le la salubrité manquant donc il
faut bien manipuler puis bien laver
avant de de manger la creuse
il faut donc traiter les crevettes comme
le poulet pour diminuer le risque de
contamination croisée est ce que vous
les achetiez crue ou cuite
on peut diminuer considérablement le
risque si on lave bien une crevette on
les décortique mon lave les et qu'on
s'assure que tout ce qui est bouillon
qui vient du sacré le liquide de
congélation est pas utilisé et éliminer
évacuer le plus vite possible pipe bien
rincer donc le fait de décortiquer et de
bien laver après la décortication ca
diminuer votre risque
il
puis on fait bien qu'eux aussi ont fait
bien cueillir parce que si on les prend
pas assez cuite
on tue pas par la chaleur les microbes
malheureusement
[Musique]